a woman is suing her ooh BRR driver for
refusing to take her to get an abortion
meanwhile leftists weep over a sack full
of puppies in a dumpster we will examine
our clinical culture then 2020 Democrats
continue to humiliate themselves and
Cher yes cher marches further down the
road to becoming a Republican I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
this is the most important story in the
news today and nobody is talking about
it a woman is trying to sue her uber
driver for not driving her to go get an
abortion there there are so many
political and cultural issues all in
this one story this story basically
epitomizes 2019 we will get to that in a
second but first I target Pro I suspect
a large number of you are gun owners
like myself but you don't have a ton of
time to practice not just time but money
too especially if you live in California
where guns are basically absolutely
illegal and they will come and hunt you
down if you exercise your Second
Amendment rights guns shooting guns can
be very expensive it's time-consuming
it's inconvenient to go to the range but
it's also necessary to do all of that
especially to protect our constitutional
rights what if you could practice in the
comfort convenience and privacy of your
own home introducing I target Pro the
first Drive fire training system to
combine smartphone technology with the
industry's best laser bullet this is a
complete game-changer
I absolutely love this thing I never
have time to go to the one or two ranges
around Los Angeles it's very expensive
it really becomes onerous especially if
you shoot very fun guns like I do i
target Pro changes all of that you can
do it while sitting on your couch using
your smartphone proprietary app tracks a
caliber specific laser fits onto your
actual firearm it will detect exactly
where your shots are landing I target
pros completely safe with a specific
laser bullet target system you can begin
training immediately right now get 10%
off plus free shipping with the offer
code Knolls KO wles
when you purchase the I target Pro
system experts agree dry fire training
is essential now it is easy and fun it
is so great if you aren't sure what to
get dad this Father's Day go to the
letter i' target procom get him
something truly cool getting the
original I target pro that is letter I
target procom promo code Knowles Canada
wles
20 year old woman in upstate New York
finds out that she's pregnant
she's not married she's got a boyfriend
she finds out she's pregnant so she
decides to go get an abortion now she
doesn't have a car up where she is I
think she's at college so she doesn't
keep a car on campus she decides to call
an uber and take her to the abortion
clinic so her abortion appointment is
11:30 in the morning her uber shows up a
couple minutes before 10:00 a.m. now
according to her the driver seemed
uneasy the driver asks her five minutes
into the ride are we going to Planned
Parenthood she says no apparently she's
not going to Planned Parenthood but
there was the address of a clinic in the
app now presumably this woman maybe she
looked pregnant
somehow this driver has a feeling she's
not just going to get her annual checkup
so the driver asks are we going to an
abortion clinic the woman remains silent
that's all all she needs to hear all the
driver needs to hear total silence so
then he says I know it's none of my
business but and he goes on to talk
about his wife his wife apparently was
pregnant or is pregnant he goes on to
talk about how the abortion peddling
industry does not give women all of the
information about it does not talk about
the huge rates of regret that women feel
afterwards he tells her she's gonna
regret this decision for the rest of her
life let's not forget Jane Roe of roe v
wade the number one iconic abortion
rights activist became a major pro-life
activist later in her life totally
regretted everything she did with regard
to abortion dr. Bernard Nathanson the
founder of nay RAL the founder of the
abortion rights organization became one
of the biggest pro-life advocates he
said they were lying
throughout the pro-abortion movement he
totally regrets what he did and what
this uber driver was saying is you are
going to regret this decision
countless scores of women who were gonna
get abortions who advocated for abortion
who considered abortions totally came to
regret it you can see them all at the
March for Life so many of them go in
March now in the March for Life so
halfway to the clinic is the clinic's
about an hour
hour and a half away he pulls over he
says I'm sorry I can't take you the rest
of the way he said I can take you back
to the city where you're from or I can
stay here and wait with you
well you call another uber he said if I
Drive you back to the city where you're
from you're not gonna be able to get
another ruber middle of upstate New York
but here I will wait with you until you
get another uber but I cannot drive you
to go get an abortion so she says no I
don't want you to wait with me she calls
her boyfriend he doesn't pick up
I guess she calls him again maybe she
calls him a third time finally he picks
up and he says oh well you've got to
call the abortion clinic and say you're
gonna be a little late
sounds like a great guy doesn't he
sounds like a real upright guy but he
really cares for her I bet it was a
really good decision to date him doesn't
go with her doesn't tell her not to get
the abortion not to kill the kid doesn't
even go with her to get the abortion
he's back doesn't even pick up her call
when she calls then he says oh yeah
you're probably gonna want to call the
abortion clinic so you're gonna be a
little bit late huh that's it click so
then she calls a cab cab takes her to
the abortion clinic
I guess she gets an abortion after this
the woman contacts uber and demands that
the driver be fired
the driver who asked her at the very
beginning are we getting in a are we
going to get an abortion right are we
going to Planned Parenthood are we going
to an abortion clinic she was quiet she
didn't he says look I'll wait with you
well you call another uber or I will
drive you back home you can try to call
it over there but I personally cannot be
complicit in killing a baby she contacts
uber says he's got to be fired
uber immediately fires the driver I'm
from north of the city in New York spent
a lot of time in upstate New York
aren't a ton of jobs up there depending
on which town you're in not the most
booming economies in upstate New York
immediately this guy loses his job for
saying that he's not going to be
complicit to an abortion but it goes
further than that
the woman now wants to sue the guy who
are refusing to take her to
go kill her child she's trying to find
out if she has a case maybe she does
what went wrong here everything
everything about this story is wrong
the most important aspect the most
glaring aspect is that we treat abortion
as though it's calling an uber I mean in
this case she's literally treating an
abortion like it's getting an uber you
hear politicians talk about abortion on
demand frivolous abortion abortion as
birth control she is literally treating
abortion as though she's calling an uber
she's conflating the two she's saying if
if you goober driver don't drive me to
the abortion you were denying my rights
you're denying my constitutional right
to an abortion I don't know where in the
Constitution that right exactly exists
but she's saying that he's denying her
rights the other aspect is that we treat
people as inconveniences rather than as
human beings we treat people as they're
the only value that they have is a value
as it relates to us obviously that's the
case of this baby
the woman has a baby she's pregnant she
wants to kill it no regard to the value
of her child no regard to its humanity
only because it's inconvenient that she
become a mother now she said that she
said at the at the top of this she's
spoken to the media and so I'm 20 years
old I'm not ready to become a mother I'm
not ready to take care of a child so I'm
going to kill it well it's not all about
you it's not all about your ability to
care for a child how about you give the
child up for adoption a lot of people in
this country want to adopt babies do
that no it's just about her about the
uber driver this guy she calls on him
asks him to perform a service he then
finds out the reality of that service he
says he doesn't want to do it and she
gets him fired she gets him to lose his
job now she's trying to take his money
she's trying to sue him how about the
boyfriend how about this dirtbag
boyfriend who knocks up his girlfriend
then tells her to go get an abortion
then doesn't go with her to get the
abortion then she gets held up she can't
get a ride to get the abortion what does
he do he finally picks up the phone he
says oh well you got
know you'll be late you you better make
sure that they don't cancel your
abortion appointment because that would
be really inconvenient to me if you
don't kill my child come on go do it
take care of it what you bothering me
for same thing this this woman is
treating this guy not as a boyfriend not
as a husband not as someone she's in
love with she's she's buying into the
feminist lie that our sexual relations
between each other are just totally
casual there totally it doesn't matter
it's not look he has no response I know
he knocked me up but he has no
responsibility for the baby no I know
I'm sighs shouldn't have even bothered
to call him that was probably wrong of
me I'm imposing on him and then we're
treating people as bigots for not
indulging our fantasies and our desires
we're treating this uber driver as
though he's somehow bigoted because he
won't indulge this woman's fantasy that
her baby isn't really a baby that the
baby that she's explicitly going to kill
somehow isn't alive or that the
offspring that she has begotten somehow
isn't human it's probably a platypus or
something it's probably like algae or a
goldfish right no it's obviously a
living human baby it's her baby this
Buber driver realizes that she's
pretending that it's not her baby and
then she's calling him a bigot because
he won't indulge in that fantasy or that
desire what I mean when we talk about
the questions of religious liberty if
this is not the religious liberty case
what is it's a man saying I politely
would like to refrain from helping to
kill a baby and this woman is using the
force of Corporate America and is trying
to use the force of the state to compel
him to participate in killing a baby
corporate America is already doing this
corporate America has already totally
destroyed his religious liberty totally
gone over his rights
uber fired him in a second oh you won't
drive a woman to go kill a baby you
won't help to do that act okay you're
done well I don't care why you object to
it you're just a bigot now she's trying
to go to the government and say I want
damages I want him to pay me because he
wouldn't help me kill my baby and it'd
have vindictive how vindictive is this
this you notice not just on a question
of abortion you see it all throughout
the country we are so vindictive to
people who don't affirm the fantasies
that we hold who don't affirm the
desires that we have we are so
vindictive if you I was on campus
yesterday at Cal State LA talking to all
of the students apparently at that
school they get a diversity manual about
this thick diversity which just means
left-wing ideology they describe all the
various sexual orientations one of them
apparently is is BDSM sadomasochism
that's now a sexual orientation and if
you object to something like BDSM you're
a bigot and you will be punished because
then you're not inclusive then you're
not accepting diversity if you don't
affirm any little thing that the left
wants you to affirm not only will you be
smeared as a bigot you will be destroyed
your career will be destroyed you will
be socially ostracized you will be
professionally ostracized you will be
politically ostracized and the
overarching theme I see from this whole
story is how clinical we treat each
other now when we people talk about
their boyfriends or their girlfriends
among my left-wing friends do you know
how they introduce them to me they say
hello Michael I'd like you to meet my
partner even if it's a straight couple
gay couple they say hey this is my
partner partner what do you have like an
accounting business together partner
you're you've invested in some stock
together you've got some corporation
together no no it's my partner and we're
in a relationship they're not in love
they're not married
they're not engaged they're not having
an affair they're in a relationship how
pathetic how pathetic is it that we have
now somehow made sex boring we've
somehow made romance bland and boring
George we'll made this point years ago
he said Cole Porter didn't sing let's do
it let's be in a relationship now he
said let's do it let's fall in love love
is a wonderful thing
romance is a wonderful thing even if in
a fair at least there's some sauce to it
at least there's some emotion to it at
least you're participating in it is a
human there's nothing human about how
clinical all them all of this is you you
have a child you beget a child and you
go to some sterile room with fluorescent
lighting and you have some sadistic
doctor killing you I don't know maybe
you have a couple drinks in a wink with
some guy down the street and you beget a
child and you say I'm gonna kill that
child and the guy just hangs around
stays around his apartment then you try
to call him because you've come into
some trouble he says I guess you'd
better call the abortion clinic let him
know you're gonna be a little late huh
mm-hmm
all right we gotta go the game's on all
right bye know how clinical how you
treat your child like you're calling an
uber and then you get the uber driver to
come and you treat him like he's some
robot like he doesn't have thoughts or
feelings
he doesn't have beliefs about anything
his beliefs don't matter because he's
inconveniencing you all that matters is
you it's it's all about you nobody else
matters not the baby not the boyfriend
not the moral law certainly not that
uber driver he's not a person he's just
some grunt who only exists to please you
and to acquiesce to any of your whims no
matter how immoral no matter how wrong
compare the reaction that this story is
getting with the reaction to a story
from Coachella over the weekend at this
story at Coachella has become now a Ford
a news story five-day news story
this from TMZ Coachella woman caught in
an utterly despicable act gosh what was
the act maybe it was this act of this
woman in upstate New York right no no
woman caught in an utterly despicable
act against puppies ok social media do
your thing to help the cops find the
culprit puppies the the story goes on
this is from TMZ this is utterly
despicable a woman in Coachella was
caught on video throwing a bag of
three-day-old puppies in a dumpster
and now cops are on the hunt to find her
the Riverside County Animal Services
released security footage showing a
woman pulling up in a white Jeep
Wrangler at a local business earlier
this week and tossing a bag filled with
seven puppies into the trash bin about
an hour later someone rummaging through
the trash bin discovered the puppies
fortunately the puppies survived the
ordeal and are being cared for at an
Orange County rescue shelter the
Riverside County Animal Services say
cops are investigating for animal
cruelty but need help identifying the
woman ok social media do your thing and
find her this became widespread outrage
throughout the country trended on
Twitter
everybody covering this for days news
organizations are still covering and
it's Wednesday when did this story break
Sunday Saturday because there were
puppies in a dumpster I like puppies I
like puppies just as much as the next
guy
I don't think we should throw puppies in
a dumpster now do babies the baby that
that woman in upstate New York killed
and then got her uber driver fired for
not killing and helping to kill and then
is suing her ooh BRR driver for not
helping to kill that baby is infinitely
more valuable than all of the puppies in
the world combined infinitely more not
just 10% more not just all some babies
are no good as some babies cry too much
and some puppies are really cute no the
worst baby in the whole wide world is
infinitely more valuable then the cutest
little puppy that's ever existed
and the left gets this exactly backwards
we talk about this all the time the left
inverts reality all the time it's not
just that it gets it a little bit wrong
we all get things a little bit wrong
that would be understandable what what
sets out this perverse ideology is it's
not even just perverse it's inverse it
gets it exactly wrong we weep for
puppies and we are totally neutral
clinical when it comes to the killing of
babies how do you explain that
I know I know all of the arguments for
abortion I've heard every argument for
abortion that has ever been made they're
not terribly compelling arguments but
I've heard them all out explain to me
how you could get yourself so worked up
over a puppy being thrown in the trash
but you could have no reaction to a
million babies a year not just this one
baby in New York a million babies a year
being killed three-day old puppy three
day old baby because we're not just
talking about abortion at this stage at
which the baby doesn't quite look like a
baby where you can convince yourself oh
it's not really a baby it's a tadpole or
something oh it's not really a baby it's
a little duck no there's it because we
respond to physical resemblance there's
a stage of human growth where you can
convince yourself oh it doesn't really
quite look like a baby also a terrible
argument by the way are we now to judge
whether people should live or die based
on how they look so what you're
advocating well I don't like the color
of his skin well I don't know he doesn't
look that he doesn't look that cute the
puppy's so much cuter is that how we're
gonna judge now but there is that stage
where people feel that way that's not
what we're talking about these days in
our abortion debates the abortion law
that was just passed in New York isn't
about a baby who's a week old
it's about a baby who's being born the
abortion law that was just passed in New
York allows babies who are being born to
be killed no questions asked no big deal
the abortion laws that are being debated
in Virginia go further than that the
governor of Ridge
you said a baby who has been born can be
killed oh it's okay listen to how
clinical he sounds when he describes
killing a baby that's already been born
there are you know when we talk about
third trimester abortions these are done
with the consent of obviously the the
mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician by
the way and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities there
may be a fetus that's non Bible so in
this particular example if a mother is
in labor I can tell you exactly what
would happen the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother the infant
would be delivered and then the infant
would be kept comfortable and then a
discussion would ensue between the
mother and the physicians as to whether
or not to kill the baby that's already
been born and is crying and moving
around on the table and then we would
call the mother and uber and the uber
driver would be compelled by the force
of Corporate America and by the state to
participate in an any number of
abortions we would like and then the
uber driver would drop her off at her
apartment and then maybe her boyfriend
would answer the phone a little bit
later in the night if he wants to no big
deal I don't understand what all the
fuss is about why are you all looking at
me like I'm some sort of sociopath who
just described killing a little baby
that was born and is crying on the table
what are you saying I'm some sort of
sociopath are you accusing me of being
somebody who would ever tolerate
throwing a puppy in a dumpster I'm not
I'm not a bad man like that I'm just
talking about killing babies who have
already been born it's no big deal
you know unless you think that we're
just pointing to Andrew Cuomo in New
York the governor or Ralph Northam
governor of Virginia as outlier
egregious examples of this don't forget
the entire cabal of Senate Democrats
voted
these sorts of laws the entire cabal of
Senate Democrats voted to deny medical
care to babies who survived abortion all
of those Senate Democrats voted to let
living babies who have been delivered
died on the table while they cry for
their mothers not just the Senate
Democrats the Democrats who are running
for the presidential nomination in 2020
here's Pete but a judge Pete but a judge
tries to play himself off as Howdy Doody
just as American as apple pie he is a
moderate he's not one of these
extremists he's asked by morning Joe
whether or not he thinks that the
abortion laws now being debated in New
York the past in New York in in Virginia
among Senate Democrats whether he thinks
they're too extreme
maybe we shouldn't kill babies as
they're being born and after they're
being born here's what mayor Pete has to
say support the late term abortion
legislation that was passed in the New
York state legislature as well as in
Virginia I don't think we need more
restrictions right now
yes that's what he says I don't think we
need more restrictions right now nine
words could have said it one word yes do
you think that we should restrict the
laws that have been passed in New York
in Virginia no we shouldn't restrict the
laws Pete but a judge asked any of the
other candidates running for the
Democrat nomination for president what
they think about abortion as babies are
being delivered we're after babies have
been delivered either as survivors of
abortions or lying on that table in
Virginia ask them what they think about
it they'll all give exactly the same
answer and they'll give that answer
because they are trapped in a clinical
lie they're trapped in the lie that love
is an illusion human beings are just
automotives they're just individuals we
have no bonds of love or kinship to
anybody else and ultimately all that
matters is not our love for the Creator
who made us is not the moral law is not
our loyalty and allegiance to our
parents and our families and our
children it's not that it's just what we
want it's all about me me me don't you
ever interfere with numero uno
I like people as much as the next guy
but stand in my way and I'll rip you to
shreds that's what they're all saying
they can't face the reality they look at
clinical fantasy they can't face the
human reality the human reality of
people like John Franklin Stephens who
every single one of those Democrats in
the Senate and running New York and
Virginia and running for president right
now think should it's perfectly
acceptable to kill they can't face
people like this man Frank Stevens who
simply want to be recognized as a human
I am a man see me as a human being
not a birth defect not a syndrome I
don't need to be Eve allocated I don't
need to be cured I need to be loved
valued educated and sometimes helped
allow me to use my life as one of them
as one example of what's possible now
every one of those Democrats Pete but a
judge the Senate Democrats Andrew Cuomo
over jigna governor Ralph Northam would
kill that man
would kill him just as soon as look at
him and if he survived their attempt to
kill him in the womb they would let him
die on the table they all voted for it
every single one of them and then
they'll cry over puppies in a dumpster
well the puppies are so cute that's the
inversion that we're dealing with that's
the politics of 2019 that we're dealing
with we're not we're not allowed to
protect little babies in the womb
according to the left we can kill
children and according to the left it is
immoral to put children on a diet it's
okay to kill them it's immoral to put
children on a diet this is a crazy news
story unless you understand the totally
inverted logic of the left we'll get to
it in one second first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube go over
to Daley wire comm 10
a month $100 for an annual membership
you get me you get the under Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you got the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up tomorrow get
your questions in you get another
Kingdom you get to ask questions
backstage you get so much and you get
the leftist ears tumblr I was at Cal
State LA yesterday the Q&A session got
pretty rowdy to say the least
there were professors at this University
who came up to me looked me in the face
and said speech is violence who said
Michael look up the definition of
violence you'll find out that speech is
violence spoiler alert I looked it up
it's not very crazy crazy professors
frankly the professors were far more
extreme and far more ignorant than the
students sure you can check that out I
assume we'll put that online today if
it's not already online you're gonna
need the leftist ears tumblr to watch it
though you can't it's like looking at a
solar eclipse you can't look at it
directly or you'll blind yourself you
have to look at it through a certain
instrument you can't watch the video at
Cal State LA directly you'll drown
yourself you have to look through it
with an instrument called the leftist
ears tumblr go to daily wire comm we'll
be right back with a lot more
according to the left we can kill our
children kill our children after they've
been born but we cannot put our children
on a diet this is according to a fat sex
therapist I'm not describing her as fat
by the way this is the title that she
goes by the fat sex therapist Sonali
Rajah toir she is non-binary she says so
I guess I'm not even allowed to use the
pronoun she' I have to call her like
Robert or Laurel I don't know I don't
know what the correct non-binary pronoun
is she was giving a lecture at the
University of Texas on the quote
business of Medical fatphobia
and here is what she has to say about
the morality of putting children on a
diet and I truly believe that a child
cannot consent to being on a diet the
way a child cannot consent to having sex
that is why identify what I experiences
child of non-consensual diets this
statement got me in a little bit of hot
water cuz folks our folks feel like we
can't call things sexual violence that
they don't if they don't include an
experience of assault but I experienced
diet culture as a form of assault
because it impacts the way that I
experience my body
you cannot after leaving this room
continue to call yourself progressive or
leftist or a radical remark fist or a
communist or socialist or or an
anarchist and still hold on to fat
phobic values because fat phobia is tied
into ableism fat phobia is Ted in two
classes and fat phobias tied into
capitalism into this understanding that
a system is telling us that there is an
inherent rank and hierarchy of body
worthiness she does make one good point
fat phobia is tied in with capitalism in
so much as because of capitalism all of
us are extremely rich and people are
getting very fat because there's a
of abundance there's a lot of wealth and
food to go around so it is true in so
much as fatphobia is tied to being fat
being fat definitely is tied to
capitalism if you want to get rid of fat
phobia you've got to get rid of people
who are fat and if you want to get rid
of people who are fat I highly recommend
socialism socialism does an incredible
job of thinning people down you can look
in Venezuela you can look in Cuba you
can look in the Soviet Union you can
look in China you can look anywhere
socialism has ever been tried you can
look to North Korea socialism does a
very good job of eradicating fatphobia
by eradicating fat people really by
eradicating people to begin with this
woman so Nellie Russia toir says that
children cannot consent to being on a
diet any more than children can consent
to having sex okay okay let's follow
that argument to its logical conclusion
what does so Nellie Russia toir think
about children who say that they are
transgender
what does sonali Russia toire think of
the treatment of children who say
they're transgender and then their
parents stop them from going through
puberty they inject them from a ton of
hormones with a ton of hormones and they
that castrate them can children consent
to being castrated can children consent
to being shot up with a bunch of
hormones can children can be consenting
to not going through puberty probably
not let's take it back a step further if
children can't consent to going on a
diet can children consent to being
killed in the womb because I don't think
you ask the babies permission when you
try to kill it in the womb and actually
we have lots of evidence that babies
fight back that they don't want to be
killed that they're in pain in some
cases they certainly from all everything
that we can tell the babies are not
consenting to being killed in the womb
even if they were even if they said yeah
bring it on we're all for it yeah what
by your logic babies are too young to
consent to being killed in the womb
surely being killed in the womb is far
more egregious than being put on a diet
or more
just than being shot full of hormones
even more egregious than being assaulted
because you're being killed where why
does that logic hold up to fat kids
being allowed to remain fat kids and not
being put on a diet by their parents but
it doesn't hold up to the transgender
argument or to killing them in the womb
something tells me this is all about
subjective preference this is all about
fantasy this is all about desires and
making everybody acquiesce to your
desires the woman calls herself the fat
sex therapist so I'll take her at her
word if you can't see the video she's
very very large she's definitely not
healthy nobody thinks that this woman is
in good physical shape when you're not
healthy when you're morbidly obese that
has very difficult health consequences
you can die sooner you can develop a lot
of illnesses you can develop type 2
diabetes you can have to go on lots of
medications you might have to be taken
care of under socialist health care
systems we all have to pay for your
medical care it's not good to be
morbidly obese doesn't mean you're
immoral doesn't mean you're gonna burn
in hell doesn't mean you're a terrible
person if you're morbidly obese but it
does mean something's wrong maybe you
can work on that thing that's wrong this
woman is not standing while she's giving
her lecture she's sitting in a big comfy
armchair I assume that's part of the
presentation I assume that's part of the
point she's trying to make which is how
dare you tell me that I should lose some
weight that it would be better if I lost
some weight she says I experience diets
as assault I think we all do we just
came out of the period of Lent
Lent is the period of a penitential
season before Easter where you're
supposed to deny yourself a lot of
people eat less food during this time
it's not fun to eat less food you are
denying yourself you're making a
sacrifice it's good to deny yourself
it's good to have discipline it's good
to make sacrifices for something that is
outside yourself but by these sorts of
arguments fatphobia just being the the
new word that we're using you could use
any of the other new words it's just a
way to rationalize prioritizing our
subjective preferences over objective
reality it seems to me this woman
doesn't want to lose weight she says as
much and her justification for why she
doesn't want to lose weight and become
healthier is it doesn't make her feel
good she's I don't wanna
that's her justification that's the
beginning in the end of her argument and
then she's trying to extrapolate her
subjective feeling to children so say if
there's some fat kid who's being fed a
diet of 5,000 calories a day and he's
really fat it's wrong of you to tell him
to lose weight why is it wrong because
if you can tell him to lose weight you
can tell me to lose weight and I don't
want to lose weight well let's take her
argument just on its face if it's
immoral to tell fat kids to go on a diet
isn't it also immoral to feed cat fat
kids are really highly caloric diet
the fat kid can't consent to go on a
diet any more than the fat kid can
consent to eat what the food that you
prepare for him fat kids don't make
their own food their kids their food is
made for them by their parents or if
their parents don't make them lunch by
the school or by the government they're
not consenting to one or the other why
is it wrong to put to put the kid on a
healthy diet but it's not wrong to put
the kid on an unhealthy diet they can't
consent well maybe the kid wants to eat
chocolate all day okay maybe he does but
he can't consent the argument of consent
can't work in the instances that are
convenient for you but not in the
instances that are inconvenient for you
you have to have a rule you have to
follow objective reality not subjective
nonsense now I think some people are
waking up to this
that's the hopeful side of it because
obviously you look at that video and you
say this is so crazy
there are a lot of people who believe it
there are a lot of people in that
audience I was at Cal State LA yesterday
and there was a girl who held up a sign
it said anti-immigrant speech is
violence and
I said no it's not she said no it is
violence I said no violence is when you
harm somebody physically nobody in this
room has been harmed physically they
said yes yes no your speech is harming
racial minority students I said there is
not virtually the entire audience was
made up of various racial minorities I
said I'm looking at all of you none of
you have been injured I'm not I can't
see there is no physical difference
between how you look now and how you
looked when you walked into the room and
there was a young black girl who called
out she said we'll have you asked any of
us if we've been injured said no I don't
need to ask you if you've been injured
because I can see with my own eyes I can
see that my words haven't left out of my
mouth and grown big fists and marched
over to you and punched you in the face
I know that's true an objective reality
now what she was trying to say that
young girl is you can never know if
you've harmed me only I can know if
you've harmed me only I can say if
you've harmed me only I can define
reality you can't perceive reality
especially as a white man or in my case
a slightly off white man you can't
define that you can't perceive anything
only I can that's not true the fat sex
therapist says that her opinions are
true because she feels them and she
really wants them to be true it's not an
argument the girl at the theatre said
we've been hurt say no you haven't show
me any evidence they say my feelings I
want to have been hurt not an argument
when I was leaving the University of
Missouri Kansas City a week or two ago
all those crazy screaming students were
walking out and they said we're
oppressed were oppressed we were you're
awful you were pressing us I said I'm
looking at you you're here in the most
prosperous country in the history of the
world you're in the most just equitable
country in the history of the world
you all have nice clothing on we're in a
very lovely place temperature controlled
room you're in a university getting a
college education you're here
voluntarily at a lecture you must be
really oppressed huh and they looked at
me dead serious with those crazy eyes
and said we are oppressed yes yes we are
no you want to be oppressed you want to
be oppressed because being oppressed
carries with it social advantage social
privileges you want to be special you
want to get certain social advantages
and so the only way that you any
American could say I am oppressed is to
say only my subjective feeling defines
reality and that is a bridge too far
even for some really out there people
that is a bridge too far even for share
I am loving this watching the
progression of share you know Sonny and
Cher the singer crazy leftist becoming
slowly a Republican that's what's
happening we're getting woke Cher
when it when you know Bill Kristol went
from being a conservative to being I
guess a liberal now or something and
he's very certainly on the left now they
they called him woke Bill Kristol now
we're getting woke cher woke cher just
tweeted out after that Town Hall we were
talking about yesterday where Bernie
Sanders and all the other candidates
said that terrorists and the Boston
Marathon bomber should be able to get
the right to vote Bernie Sanders said
that the Boston Marathon bombers should
get the right to vote in prison
cher tweeted out does Bernie Sanders
really believe people in prison who are
murderers there's a crazy
capitalizations and strange spelling so
bear with me who are rapists who are
child molesters than all caps Boston
bombers still deserve the right to vote
yes Bernie Sanders really believes that
it's not just Bernie though Chris Cuomo
and Don Lemon asked all the other
candidates said you don't agree with
Bernie Sanders that the Boston Marathon
bomber should have the right to vote
right and what did Kamala Harris say
well I know it's very important I think
we have to have that conversation so
what s Pete but a judge do you think
that terrorists and rapists should have
the right to vote well yeah yeah
absolutely certainly once they've gotten
out of prison yeah absolutely and Don
Lemon and Chris Cuomo both Democrats
both left wingers looking at him like
are you kidding me what are you doing to
my party this is an extreme and people
are waking up to this people are waking
up to this the phobia language fat foot
what is fat phobia
it's the irrational fear of being in bad
health it's not an irrational fear
that's a perfectly rational fear plenty
of people have it I have fears about
behaviors that I engage in I try to stop
those behaviors people are waking up to
all of this subjective crazy language
which has led us to these extreme policy
positions where now you have the leading
Democrat candidates for president
advocating giving terrorists who have
murdered Americans the right to vote the
right to select the president while they
are in prison share had previously
tweeted out quote I understand helping
struggling immigrants but my city Los
Angeles isn't taking care of its own
what about the 50,000 plus citizens who
live on the streets people who live
below poverty people who are hungry if
my state can't take care of its own many
are veterans how can it take care of
more waking up there saying wait a
second you're telling me that we're
gonna let in a 3,000 foreign nationals a
day come into our country and on average
use more welfare programs over
generations than native-born Americans
and on average commit more federal
crimes than native-born Americans and
are you we're gonna hold on hold on
that's a little too much even for me so
share Don Lemon Chris Cuomo they might
all share the premises of this radical
left
they just haven't followed them to their
logical conclusions and as those
arguments reach their logical
conclusions I think we're gonna see a
lot of people wake up say gosh that
that's not what I meant to do at all
sorry we got a reverse course yes Louis
talks about this when you're going down
a road when you're going in the wrong
direction the guy to stop and turn
around go in the other direction is the
real progressive he's he's the only one
who's progressive you might think you're
both marching down the road to progress
if you're going in the wrong direction
the guy who turns around he's the
progressive I think we're gonna get a
lot more woke people in addition to
share as this 2020 race goes on that's
our show I'm gonna be sitting in for Ben
on the radio show today
so be sure to tune in for that there'll
be a lot of fun in the meantime get your
mailbag questions in I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today an uber driver has been
fired for refusing to take a woman to
get an abortion it's an interesting case
I believe the driver is heroic and in
what he did but should he have been
fired as he was and does the woman have
a legal case now against the driver of
as she prepares to sue him does she have
a case at all we'll talk about that also
Charlize Theron says that her
three-year-old son discovered magically
that he's really a girl we'll discuss
that and following up on a conversation
from yesterday I have been told that I
lacks sympathy for college graduates
because I don't want their student loans
forgiven so we'll talk about that a
little bit more and what actually is the
sympathetic and compassionate position
to take on this subject we'll discuss
that today on the Matt Walsh show